joining me now is former President of
Mexico and frequent Trump critic Vicente
Fox he's the author of a brand new book
just out let's move on beyond fear and
false prophets he's an author and we've
been chatting about a lot of things it's
great to see you how are you welcome
thank you for inviting me assume plus it
and I said we're gonna do the whole
thing in Spanish but it's not quite as
good as good as I need to be to do that
but president Fox you heard some of the
the monologue there your reaction to
Trump at Davos I mean you have said
everything from you've compared him to
Hitler you said he's an ugly American
rude racist going to start a war not a
real leader one year into the Trump
administration the American economy is
thriving manufacturing is up wages and
some sectors are up confidence is at an
all-time high african-american
unemployment 17-year low since since it
was recorded so many great barometers
but you really have nothing positive to
say about him no but let me tell you
it's good that the economy moves we all
move the world economy before Trump and
withdrawn is getting close to 5% growth
so it's dynamic and it's growing in the
out world eighty percent of the economy
of the global economies outside of the
United States so yes there might be
something to recognize to Trump in the
sense that economic activity pretty much
depends on expectations so what is still
waiting to see that all of this comes to
be true and then the canary will keep on
going but you attribute that to Obama or
you tribute to Trump's jobs coming back
the United States and all that
attributed to US citizens to
corporations to universities they're
responding to his powerful so great the
Trump campaign moves on these songs
don't moves on its own there's no
there's no country could not have a
president doing better I'm sure
okay that's wild okay that
wild I got a spoon I think the Spanish
word for what I'm thinking it's gonna
come to my six mark without a lot
clothes and they grew up alright let's
talk about the White House immigration
proposal and issues that you really care
a lot about it came out tonight this is
Becca the doc 1.8 million Dhaka dreamers
protected that's a million more than the
eight hundred thousand he was offering
to help last week twenty five billion
for border wall and security eliminate
the visa lottery change it those fifty
thousand a year would go toward the
people now waiting in line to come
legally and keeping the nuclear family
together but ending the extended family
chain migration 1.8 million people given
amnesty yeah 1 million more than what he
said last week but 1 million name what
he said two weeks ago here I hope he
gains credibility because everybody
doubts that that will happen in my only
concern is that is condition2 getting
twenty five billion US dollars from
Congress so that makes me happy because
then Mexico's not gonna pay for it so US
Congress and taxpayers I want to pay for
that wall number two it doesn't make me
happy because to exchange one young
dreaming person that expects a great
future for himself for one dollar
I would not exchange it for twenty five
thousand I will need either exchange so
I don't know why you have to tie up
together these two things
let's get those kids really supported
they want to stay here and if not we
welcome them in Mexico we would love to
have them they have university degrees
and they are great human talent now on
the case of the twenty five thousand how
many good things you can do with twenty
five times one word okay well you've
never been a big fan of the wall to say
the least you've called Trump again rude
all these racist other things like like
equal lots of rapists and criminals no
he didn't say that he said and when he
announced he was running he said they're
sending
a rapist and he said there are other
people who are good people coming across
I think you know that's a manner of
speech you have manners of speeches in
Spanish we have move different ways but
I mean you you do understand that Mexico
has a problem keeping her own people in
her country satisfying their economic
needs with satisfying their need to be
safe from criminals so they flee your
country and come to our country why
can't you keep your own people happy in
your own country you gonna blame Trump
for that too no let me see what I'm
different from you on this NAFTA was
created for that purpose exactly for
that purpose to bring into Mexico
wealth jobs so that migration will be
reduced in why we still get something
let me tell you the real facts when
NAFTA started you would make $1.00 on
the Mexican side in ten dollars on the
US side we're not sorry I've got a sixty
three billion dollar deficit instead of
one yeah 25 years later today it's five
to one so it has come from think we're
subs that we're subsidizing Mexicans are
through NAFTA oh you're nuts hope so
that's you man we can't do an hour on
NAFTA because I want to get to some
other things because you're after was
supposed to be a great tool that's great
for you we you have a sixty three
billion dollar trade surplus it's
awesome GM Chrysler and about us company
in Mexico is a return to you move their
companies any day of the week they want
to Mexico if they want to do that they
can do that but where our policies are
no longer going to encourage that that's
what President Trump says farming now we
import forty billion small percentage
compared in pharmacy you're not in the
stands that V big agro wants to wants to
do let's go back to what what Newsweek
said about you when you were president
this was back in 2006 Vicente Fox has
spent the past five years
urging the United States to upgrade the
status of millions of illegals from
Mexico meanwhile his own gov
has given legal status to only 15,000
foreigners without papers you deported
140,000 in 2003 deported 120,000 in 2002
and from 2002 to 2006 the number of
detain Monsanto was up 74% so your trash
in the United States for deporting
Mexicans and other people from our
country we don't do that much and
meanwhile you are deporting plenty of
people and you had lots of problems with
the way immigrants were treated in the
early part especially of your tenure yes
yes that is true and those people are my
heroes and they contribute to this
economy like nobody else or like
everybody else who is your heroes I'm
not following by channels my dear
Hispanic Paisano's Mexicans here in this
way but why did you deport why did you
only give legal status when you were
president to illegal immigrants in your
country to only fifteen thousand people
we didn't have the capacity because
we're one time Trump is Hitler so like
possible so you could only bring it you
can only give 15 to us we had to get rid
of all these hundreds and hundreds of
thousands no but you were Mexico
President of Mexico yes you've got poor
grades for the way you treated my Mexico
is full employment would you believe
that's because of that's because you
guys have a 63 billion dollar deficit
because yeah you work NAFTA but it's
gonna be renegotiated are you happy
about that do you remember the times
when united states would force all of us
to open our markets from World War two
year 2000 why does it that's why this
nation grew so much by trading with the
rest of the world
yeah well China has the mr. president I
am NOT denying that NAFTA has been great
for Mexico but we actually have two
states we have a sixty three billion
dollar trade deficit with Mexico that
cannot Ottawa and it's mostly automobile
it's not a prime agricultural automobile
my question to you is what about China
why don't you do this
well we are in the process yeah or or
doing it I mean these jobs you look you
know what I love yeah I'm gonna say with
all of your you know movies like you did
the you gave the middle finger to Trump
and you know you're like a distinguished
you know elder statesman and you're
doing videos where you're putting up the
middle finger to the president saying f
this F that if Trump is rude and all
these things why are you why you
offended us but why are you doing the
same the rest of the world not that you
should that was not true his diplomacy
is diplomacy his presidency he's
offending the rest of the world by
America coming back stronger
well if that's offending the rest of the
world I'm not really worried about the
rest of world being offended they didn't
like Reagan did that they didn't like
Reagan remember what they called him
Reagan you did but the rest of the world
in this no we love them we have a lot of
Mexicans living in the United States why
is that an offense to you I love the
Mexican people I just want the America
but immigration needs to work for our
country just like it needs to work at
the truth so one control of Mexico
1.8 million dreamers amnesty you'll like
that yes but not condition to 25 million
US dollars so we have any border with
Mexico at this point do we need a border
really there's no choice okay but you
what you would prefer not to have an
address okay so we shouldn't have a
border god he didn't create borders do
you have a fancy you shouldn't have a
border they like you're okay with Canada
will happen this will happen in this
next generation okay because we are
going to be on a one to one wall thing I
love the fact that you adopted your four
children that is so admirable that's a
lesson to you
so we have three children three and four
good to see you all right